[Music]
you did me a solid lately old chum you
know I was hosting the MTV Movie Awards
and you helped me out with a bit we shot
we combined the categories of best fight
and best kiss and made it best kiss
fight yeah I got a lot of people telling
me they really liked that let's take a
look at this clip from Will Arnett nyan
best kiss fight best kiss fight
[Applause]
[Music]
what I love I love Conan's look on the
end of that he is there's so much
emotion going you're confused to
blending different thoughts going
through my head but happy and looks like
I did do you a solid huh but at last
yeah we get it yeah
so the it's like Conan's dream come true
you know I mean like you've been
planning it for years i right you
weren't surprised to get the call that I
wanted to rest no no it was not
I just asked for a kiss then hosting
some awards to get around it get so
elaborate do you feel like I was given
off a certain chemistry when we were
wrestling around first of all no and I
don't know but no I didn't feel like I
did feel like that we did have something
and and I would be a fool not to take a
shot
[Applause]